and then there was John he and I were  spending a lot of time together he wants  to design it's a magic trick okay this  is your pickle okay okay  I only work with pickles all right all  right now keep it  don't ever not look at my hand don't  look at the pickle don't ever not look  at my okay right here one two three  see it's gone Wow  we're about amazing that you've worked  on that a long time very long really  don't ask me to do a card trick I only  do magical trick I hate pickles  I love pickles I'll eat your pickles  forever  okay is that how you impress all the  girls with your pickle are you impressed  huh  I don't know  she did it over text you want to see it  right there  I am inaud into our relationship anymore  it sounds because I just feel like I  don't know what went wrong